public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
nicolas dupont aignan est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité ici au salon de
l'agriculture bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous donc à ce rendez-vous
de public sénat avec la sp avec radio
classique illégalement avec les échos
vous répondrai dans cette émission à
trois grandes questions sachant que vous
êtes ici bien sûr c'est un passage
obligé pour un candidat à la
présidentielle vous le président de
debout la france un oui c'est tous les
ans d'ailleurs pour vient de semba
simplement parce que je dis je serai là
jeudi toute la journée je dis voilà et
donc pas seulement parce que c'est un
passage obligé parce que non parce que
chaque année je viens même s'il ya
beaucoup à dire sur le décalage entre la
réalité ce que vivent nos agriculteurs
et le salon voilà ce qu'ils vivent ccba
pour beaucoup d'entre eux la misère c
sera d'ailleurs la première question que
vous posera dans un instant jean francis
pécresse comment sortir l'agriculture
française de la crise et donc beaucoup
d'éleveurs notamment et d'agriculteurs
de la misère deuxième question que vous
posera guillaume daudin le climat actuel
de la campagne présidentielle avec des
invectives avec des mises en cause les
magistrats les médias avec des violences
également et puis des mots assez fort
chez certains candidats est ce que ce
climat vous inquiète
enfin troisième question la
présidentielle sera t-elle selon vous un
référendum pour ou contre l'europe vous
répondrai tout à l'heure à mickaël
szames s mais d'abord une première
question d'actualité
[Musique]
nicolas dupont aignan la campagne
présidentielle est également rythmée par
les sondages a ils sont quotidiens en ce
moment vous les suivez
on les suit tous on va pas faire
semblant mais on sait qu'ils valent rien
ils ne valent rien on est alors quand je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que les
sondages c'est une photographie à
l'instant t qui est partiel souvenez
vous monsieur hamon il était à 2 % quand
il a commencé sa campagne
c'est lui le candidat du parti
socialiste monsieur fillon il était à 8
et je parle pas des exemples étrangers
donc est-ce qu'on peut arrêter de parler
que des sondages qui auto entretiennent
ceux qui nous gouvernent depuis tant
d'années qui nous font tant de mal je
donne le chiffre vous concernant puisque
entre 3 et 8 selon les sondages bien
joli 3 plutôt 3% alors nous a vraiment
légitimement où est votre espace
politique est bien quand monsieur fillon
était face à monsieur juppé et sarkozy
vous les journalistes vous passiez votre
vie à lui dire où est votre espace
politique comme monsieur hamon s'est
présenté tout le monde lui disait où est
votre espace politique
quand monsieur trump s'est présenté tout
le monde rit caennais en disant il est à
1%
alors est ce qu'un jour on va arrêter de
suivre des sondages qui sont payés par
les grands partis est publié dans des
journaux qui appartiennent à certaines
ligues archi donc moi j'aimerais qu'on
laisse les français se positionner en
fonction de ce qu'ils pensent et pas en
fonction des sondes aa donc laisser les
français jugent ils savent eux que vous
irez jusqu'au bout vous serez pas un
second yannick jadot mais enfin vous me
prenez pour qui
j'ai des convictions à défendre j'ai
d'ailleurs vous parlez des sondages mais
regardez aux dernières élections
régionales ça se sont pas des sondages
j'ai fait près de 7 % en ile-de-france
et mon parti a fait autant de voix que
le front de gauche de monsieur mélenchon
donc pourquoi sortir toujours des
sondages pour rabaisser les idées
nouvelles
en vérité vous savez c'est un peu comme
en économie
en france je pense pas que steve jobs
aurait inventé à paul dans son garage
on aurait dit tu es petit tu peux pas y
arriver moi je dis aux français c'est à
vous de trancher pas aux sondages
alors tous les cas un autre chiffre est
ce que vous avez vous 500 parrainages
aux émirats vous présentons le sort à la
fin de la semaine
mais bon
r les maires parraine et j'espère que
très vite on aura les parrainages
maintenant ça dépend pas de moi et je
fais appel aussi à l'indépendance des
mers parce qu'il ya certains partis qui
veulent pas du tout que je sois candidat
et c'est durant ce moment là pour vous
c'est pas facile parce qu'à des
pressions terribles on les aura vous les
aurez tous les cas je serais pas là vous
êtes un candidat déterminé évidemment un
nicolas dupont aignan et d'ailleurs vous
publié dans quelques jours ce livre mon
agenda de président je vois 100 jours
pour tout changer vous mettez déjà dans
la peau un de celui qui va entrer à
l'elysée personne n'a écrit un livre
comme ça pourquoi j'ai fait ça c'est
pour que les français aient l'idée
précise de ce que je ferais pendant 100
jours
si j'étais élu et il y en a tellement
assez des promesses
il n'y a pas beaucoup de français qui
croient aux promesses à juste titre et
en même temps il ya des choix à faire
fondamentaux fondamentaux pour les
années à venir et je veux pas qu'on n'en
reprennent pour cinq ans et tout est
fait aujourd'hui on va parler du climat
de la campagne avec guillaume daudin
tout est fait on parle pas des vrais
choix politiques à faire des vraies
solutions à apporter au pays pour qu'on
vive mieux on fera les aborder bien sûr
dans cette émission un mais je note
quand même que d'emblée vous dites que
vous voulez tourner la page de tous les
pouvoirs qui se sont succédé dans notre
pays et vous les traitez carrément
d'incapables et de corrompus oui on en
parlant aussi d'en parler c'est la
réalité
alors maintenant j'accueille donc jean
francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique
l'épreuve de vérité
crédit cassis et les échos bonsoir jean
françois ont ce soir michel bonsoir
nicolas dupont aignan alors question
simple et à la fois très compensant
monsieur pécresse comment sauver comment
sauver l'agriculture française de la
crise a tout simplement déjà en réglant
la question majeure de la concurrence
déloyale en restaurant une organisation
de marché en protégeant nos agriculteurs
parce que ce qui est extravagant dans la
situation d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
avait une politique qui marchait et que
nos dirigeants incapables et corrompus
et je maintiens ont détruit le cadre qui
permettait aux agriculteurs de vivre
je suis très bref qu'est ce que vous
attendez des sols monsieur pécresse
concrètement traitement j'étais l'un des
seuls à dire sous nicolas sarkozy
quand françois fillon premier ministre
détruisaient les quotas laitiers que ça
allait être une catastrophe industrielle
agricole
on m'a dit non la suppression des quotas
laitiers tout va aller bien
eh bien on a vu le résultat et quand
j'ai demandé au président hollande de
revoir cette décision dramatique de
l'europe
il a dit je peux rien faire quand on a
supprimé les prix garantis du lait
supprimer les prix garantis du lait et
supprimer le système des quotas ont
condamné à mort des milliers d'éleveurs
on le savait il le savait mais ils n'ont
pas fait parce qu'ils obéissent à
bruxelles est ce que vous allez en plus
pouvoir en france que vous êtes en train
de nous dire que roule souverainiste
vous êtes pour le retour à une politique
agricole commune européenne
je suis et wendel à pâques gelé toujours
un privé en mai la pac
non j'ai toujours défendu l'idée d'une
europe organisé qui respecte les peuples
qui protège les nations c'est à dire la
première europe
une fois qu'on a construit la pac il y
avait quoi il y avait une préférence
communautaire c'est-à-dire un
protectionnisme communautaire il y avait
un prix garanti
il y avait des organisations de marché
et ensuite les gouvernements français
ont démissionné
et face à leurs partenaires et ont cédé
c'est à dire qu'on a détruit les sens de
la politique agricole commune et on a
abouti au pire des soa pire des
solutions qui est un système dérégulé où
on n'a même pas la protection que les
éleveurs canadiens ou américains ont le
droit d'avoir il faut bien une pac
il faut bien une police ad périchole non
ou oui amis en ont un jeu vous dire soit
on refait négociations et on restaure
une vraie politique agricole commune et
à ce moment là on l'avait un quota de
production c'est ça ce que bien sûr et
les prix garantis des prix garantis pour
que les éleveurs ne vivent pas pas les
éleveurs seulement 2 ne vivent pas de
subventions mais de prix garantis
c'était l'esprit de la pac soit on
revient des prix garantis
oui des prix garantis des organisations
de marché qui régule et à ce moment là
on garde la pac soit nos partenaires ne
vole pas légions renationaliser pack
l'esprit de la pac pardon c'était la
régulation des volumes
oui à la régulation il y avait des
priorités très bien la conséquence de sa
wii mais surtout les deux ensembles
production les pardonnez moi mais c'est
ce que quand vous entendez une rançon
matin ici même dire qu'il faut franciser
les aides de la politique européenne de
la pac est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça pas totalement parce que elle
part du principe qu'on ne peut plus rien
reconstruire au niveau de la pac et je
pense qu'il faut d'abord essayer de
reconstruire la pac sur des bases
solides et si on échoue alors oui il y
aura toujours la possibilité de revenir
à des aides nationales mais je pense
comme toujours qu'il est préférable de
renégocier l'impact c'est à dire de
mettre en place un système qui protège
nos agriculteurs et qui fait que comme
au canada comme aux états unis d'une
autre façon d'une autre façon oui est
différente
oui mais tous les pays protègent et
financent leurs agricultures antonia que
l'union européenne qui a détruit le
système et qui met en péril de vie ou de
mort nos exploitations et aussi nos
éleveurs il ya ce chiffre terrible et je
rendrai hommage jeudi
aux centaines d'agriculteurs qui se sont
suicidés il y en a plus d'ailleurs on
donne même plus le chiffre tellement ils
ont peur d'avouer ce chiffre et vous
savez mais ce qui me rend non juste un
point c'est très important celui de rome
aussi important attendez ce qui me rend
mal à l'aise dans ce salon c'est de voir
tous ceux qui vivent de l'agriculture
qui sont en train de faire crever les
agriculteurs et les agriculteurs font ça
c'est inacceptable et pardon mais les
avancées qui savent ils savent aussi ce
qu'ils doivent à la politique agricole
commune européenne et il savait
maintenant n'avait pas les directs de la
pac il ne boucle rêve c'est pas vrai
leur flanc droit là c'est pas vrai mais
écoutez vous avez vous allez répondre à
la présidente par intérim de la fnsea
justement qui extrait bien point de vue
c'est christiane lambert et qui rejette
donc effectivement les anathèmes contre
l'europe d'ailleurs
à l'instar de son prédécesseur xavier
beulin acquis
j'en profite pour rendre hommage aux
etats unis son grand l'amérique du sud
est très grande et organiser les pays
d'asie qui sont en pleine croissance en
organiser pour être puissants et
solidaire la france ne peut pas rester
isolé le repli serait pas une bonne
chose pour l'agriculture française qui
échangent beaucoup commerce beaucoup et
qui tire aujourd'hui beaucoup dé la
valeur qu'elles génèrent justement des
marchés européens nous exportons d'abord
vers l'europe toutes les agriculteurs
français
vallier d'europe mais ça veut rien dire
oh no répète ça depuis 20 ans on nous
répète ces âneries depuis 20 ans je le
dis parce que eux il n'est pas question
de fermer tout il est question d'avoir
une concurrence loyale
quand vous acceptez que des produits
cancérogènes arrive sur le sol français
quand vous acceptez que des agriculteurs
européens utilisent des produits
interdits en france que d'un côté vous
avez des normes très élevées en france
et de l'autre une concurrence déloyale
quand vous casser les quotas laitiers et
que vous casser toute l'organisation de
marches et c'est l'europe et elle est
belle cette europe là l'europe c'est ce
qu'on en fait et c'est pas en ayant se
divertissent oui mais pour madame
lambert l'europe s'est bâtie en
plastique d'exploration en attendant si
paie par exemple j'ai jamais dis
attendez je veux répondre j'ai jamais
dit qu'il fallait pas d'europe
j'ai dit que quand y'a un tiers des
agriculteurs qui gagnent moins de 350
euros par mois que ya un agriculteur qui
se suscite tous les trois jours ces
paroles sont indignes indigne parce
qu'il ya un moment où il faut protéger
des gens qui sont en train de mourir
ce sont les symboles de la première
organisée lors janvier super oui mais
est-ce que je vais vous dire une
première médiation reste ionesco
agriculteurs commencent en avoir assez
qu'elle ne les défendent pas et c'est
pas en répétant l'europe l'europe
l'europe qu'on va y arriver il faut
organiser l'europe
il s'agit pas de se refermer il s'agit
de défendre nos intérêts de manière
calme déterminé et de permettre à nos
agriculteurs d'avoir un prix
rémunérateur d'éviter que la grande
distribution les exploitent d'alléger
les charges salariales
en un mot un plan de sauvetage complet
que je propose et c'est pas en répétant
l'europe l'europe
arrivé c'est au contraire en soignant
les mots et en étant ferme à bruxelles
c'est avec des discours comme ça depuis
quinze ans qu'on a le désert agricole
français donc à un moment il faut
arrêter et j'invite les électeurs à
l'élection présidentielle à se prendre
en main et arrêté ses bavardages nicolas
dupont aignan est ce que vous ne vous
dit pas quand même par moment que votre
remède risque d'être pire que le mal du
tout il y as que le renfermé
l'agriculture français sur ses
frontières alors fermé c'est le deuxième
exportateur oui mais est-ce que vous ne
vous dites vous confondez deux choses
non mais il ya 9 milliards attendus
on donne on donne à l'union européenne
par an 21 milliards atteint sa gare on
en reçoit 14 on en reçoit treize ou
quatorze 14 dans ses treize quartiers
plus efficient pour l'offre pour les
attardés non dans ces 13 et 14 il ya les
neuf de la pac mais c'est de l'argent
français
donc quand on va commencer à faire
comprendre aux français que quand on
marque c'est de l'argent européen c'est
faux c'est leur argent qui part à
bruxelles brussels en garde le tiers
pour subventionner nos concurrents c'est
à dire que l'argent des français
subventionne aux concurrents et on nous
renvoie de l'argent est là on nous dit
vous avez des remerciements c'est le
même marché sinon c'est le seul marché
nos concurrents et 500 millions de
consommateurs
on a le sentiment que vous vous levez du
tout ramenés ce marché n'est pas du tout
consommateur mais c'est qu'ils ne payent
pas mais notre marché à sion de valeur
qui ne payent pas l'elysée n'en
produisent agrippé accès à lens juste
valeur vous comprenez pas une chose le
marché il est pas seulement européen il
est mondial bien sûr qu'il est mondiale
et bien alors est-ce que vous donnez de
l'argent aux états unis est ce que vous
donnez de l'argent au japon est ce que
moi je refuse de donner l'argent n'a pas
tranché avec leurs phares dont il y en a
pas non plus avec les autres je refuse
de donner de l'argent à des pays qui
avec mon argent supprime les charges
sociales et nous renvoient des
travailleurs détachés qui payent pas les
charges sociales en france
c'est surréaliste ce qui se passe je ne
suis pas contre l'europe
je suis contre un système qui nous tue à
petit feu qui nous met en concurrence
déloyale et on n'a pas le droit de le
dire en france mais semé
ce qu'on ne peut pas de manière
raisonnable prévoir des organisations de
marché qui nous protège par exemple dire
à bruxelles maintenant ça suffit ça
suffit on va avoir un système de
protection communautaire
on va rétablir des quotas et des prix
garantis et si vous ne voulez pas on
s'en va et vous ferez sans nous et je
peux vous dire que les 8 milliards qu'on
leur donne il leur sert beaucoup et il
est paye en plus à des salaires
exorbitants coquin il n'y a pas un une
personne à bruxelles ni à paris dans les
médias eux dans la vie politique et
accepteraient de payer moins de 350
euros pour travailler 70 à 80 heures par
semaine
il n'y a pas une personne qui
accepterait ça on est tous bénins n'est
pas tous d'accord puisque on a pris les
mesures on a pris les mesures pour
affaiblir nos agriculteurs donc
maintenant vous savez c'est une question
de survie et j'ai un projet politique
pour que justement on réforme l'europe
qu'on tape du poing sur la table
qu'on ait des dirigeants qui défendent
les français donc on va le faire tout
seul ça parce qu'on n'a aucun partenaire
vous présentez nous subissons dans cette
voie là mais il vient nous suivre mais
aucun ne suis pas là aujourd'hui
ouais et mais il nous suivrons sinon on
s'en va comme les anglais d'europe du
nord notre modèle vient de politiques
locaux et vient il alors c'est très bien
donc ils feront sans nous et ils feront
sans s'en passera d'accord très bien
merci
jean francis siméon maintenant vous avez
eu des mots très durs tout à l'heure
très dur je les assure certaines
enseignes j'imagine ou sur wii tennis
qui sont ici représentés sur le salon
vous dites c'est eux qui font crever les
pays dont les deux qui sait jamais à qui
pensez-vous précisément je pense à être
certaine grande distribution je pense à
ces sociétés comme lactalis
je pense à toutes ces sociétés qui ont
des stands absolument magnifiques ici
mais s'il n'y a pas derrière des gens
qui bossent qui triment qui se sacrifie
ils sont quoi eux et j'aimerais que
l'état le pouvoir politique à un moment
fasse régner un peu de justice dans
notre société et je peux vous dire que
de payer le lait 4 à 5 centimes de plus
ne va pas empêcher toutes les enseignes
qui ont des belles enseignes dans ce
salon de vivre et
c'est le rôle de l'état c'est le rôle
des pouvoirs politiques à un moment de
défendre son peuple et ça n'enlèvera
rien aux grandes enseignes
mais c'est ce qu'on appelle les règles
très bien il ya des règles dans la vie
et en république à des lois voilà ne
doivent pas être fait pour les puissants
en laissant mourir les faibles la suite
de l'épreuve de vérité avec guillaume
daudin de l' agence france presse qui
nous rejoint maintenant l'épreuve du
penseur guillaume bonsoir votre question
à nicolas dupont aignan candidat pour la
seconde fois à l'élection présidentielle
bonsoir monsieur dupont-aignan sont
voulait revenir avec vous sur les
déclarations de françois fillon sur le
climat de guerre civile dans la campagne
on a eu les concerts de casseroles à la
fin de plusieurs de ses meetings on a eu
les manifestations du avec le front
national à la fin du meeting de emmanuel
macron à toulon on a eu les bus dégradée
du front national à nantes ce week-end
est ce que vous vous partagez ce se
constate françois fillon sur climat de
guerre civile
je pense que les paroles sont très
excessive par les guerres civiles c'est
excessif en revanche il ya un climat de
tension et je pense qu' al crime
attention parce que le débat n'est pas
là encore est pas vous personnellement
les médias ont une immense
responsabilité d une politique aussi
c'est que si on parle pas des solutions
si on n'échange pas personne à la vérité
révélée mais s'il n'y a pas ce débat on
est à moins 60 jours de la
présidentielle et les vrais sujets ne
sont pas abordés et donc il ya une
crispation populaire le sentiment que
finalement à quoi ça sert de voter
à quoi ça sert la démocratie puisque ce
sont toujours les mêmes qui parlent qui
s'exprime et ceux qui ont des idées un
peu différente on les fait taire alors
écoutez j'en sais quelque chose et on
parlera sans doute de ce scandale du
débat tf1 envahir 20 mars écoutez c'est
un reflet de ce que vous dites cette
frustration des français par rapport à
ce débat ce sont ces éleveurs ces
agriculteurs qui s'exprime sur le salon
et qui effectivement restent sur leur
faim en ce moment mais carrément encore
hors sujet c'est une place à prendre ils
se battent tous pour la voir et
promettre tous des grands programmes des
révolutions complète à chaque fois et à
chaque fois la déception est là même à
l'heure actuelle il ya quand même des
sujets qui viennent troubler cette
campagne présidentielle qui sont quand
même deux dernières minutes relativement
un peu lisible je dirais on se focalise
sur des affaires plus ou moins
judiciaire en cours ou à venir
et puis les sujets qui me semble
important c'est à dire bon la france
mais surtout la france dans l'europe
mais surtout leur dans le monde enfin
c'est ça leur parle que des casseroles
que des affaires les vrais problèmes de
politique on les aborde pas les vrais
problèmes pour qui que les gens
voudraient que ce soit traité je pense
sont jamais abordées
propos recueillis par quentin calmer
tout à l'heure et voilà on a ce monsieur
qui parle des casseroles judiciaires et
il ya françois fillon et marine le pen
qui sont un peu visés par ces affaires
judiciaires qui ont proposé une solution
en gros c'est la trêve judiciaire
pendant la campagne
est ce que c'est une bonne solution pour
vous je crois pas quand y'a pas
d'actions judiciaires ont dit la justice
n'est pas indépendante quand il y en a
certains s'en plaignent moins écouté
debout la france il ya pas de casseroles
à debout la france on a des propositions
j'étais le sol dans l'hémicycle quand il
ya quinze jours et j'ai pas vu les
députés républicains de monsieur fillon
j'ai pas vu les députés front national
pour voter le casier judiciaire vierge
pour se présenter aux élections
tiens il y avait pas grand monde en été
vains et il a fallu même se battre
contre le gouvernement donc moi je fais
des propositions je suis candidat
différent parce que je suis un homme
politique profondément différents 2e
j'ai rompu avec eux il ya dix ans j'ai
pris mes risques
j'ai ramé il ya de plus en plus de
français qui me soutiennent c'est
beaucoup plus dur que pour les autres on
me demande dix fois plus d'efforts pour
voir le même temps de parole j'en suis à
fois moins de temps de parole et je suis
convaincu qu'à une voix pour la france
mais deux donc de 7 c est moi je veux
proposer des choses différentes aux
français mais c'est tout après jamais de
fait dans le débat public enseignants
bien ses affaires judiciaires pour vous
la justice ne doit pas s'arrêter mais
elle doit accélérer avant les élections
et elle ne doit pas s'arrêter
la seule remarque je fais c'est que si
la justice traîne est patent au fil de
l'année
peut-être qu'ils se réveillent mais
moins vite au dernier moment
j'aimerais c'est que la justice elle
passe naturellement et qu'elles soient
pas si longue parce que le problème
judiciaire français que ce soit
d'ailleurs pour le petit délinquant ou
délinquants en col blanc c'est qu'on
attend des années et que comme on attend
des années on sait jamais où on en est
et ça profite aux gros et ce que j'ai
trouvé scandaleux c'est le vote le vote
qui a eu lieu où la prescription des
délits financiers a été arrangé par le
monde politique et financier tout
récemment c'est quand même extravagant
ce qui s'est passé c'est à dire que la
prescription a été allongée pour les
crimes et les délits et pour les délits
financiers les alors là ça a été remis
au point de départ et non au point de
deux naissances de l'infraction est pas
à la découverte
alors vous reprochez à tf1 de ne pas
vous inviter lors du premier grand débat
présidentiel
je crois que vous vous allez porter
plainte vous avez porté plainte mais je
trouve que vous avez fait exactement
d'abord j'ai saisi le csa qui se
déterminent demain si le csa ne fait pas
respecter la loi sur l'équité qui
demandent de prendre en compte les
derniers résultats électoraux
j'ai fait autant de voix que le front de
gauche je devrais être invité tf1 ne se
base que sur des sondages
et bien si le sait ça ne rappelle pas
alors tf1 je saisirai le conseil d'état
pour cette affaire où vous êtes chez
enseignement monde une augmentation
médiatique c'est ça comment vous avez le
sentiment manquer de passages
médiatiques que je regarde les chiffres
l'équité c'est quoi l'équité c'est que
j'ai fait 4 % aux dernières européennes
et régionales
je devrais avoir mon parti 4% d'antenne
c'est ça les quitter vous savez combien
je suis l'un pour les 19 premiers jours
l'année dernière 0 3 % sur tf1
rtl france inter 0 0 ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que dans la vie politique
française on ne veut pas qu émergent des
courants nouveau on veut pas que les
français aient le choix et on les rend
prisonnier d'un dilemme soit on continue
avec ceux qui nous ont tué à petit feu
sont pas au front national
sks jour je crois que tf1 maintient son
projet le 20 mars et j'appelle les
français les cinq favoris allégerait les
français à boycotter cette chère et côté
tf1 oui parce que c'est pas le cas
dupont aignan qui est en cause c'est la
vision qu'on a de notre démocratie
merci guillaume d'un troisième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant on change
de thématiques
enfin pas complètement avec michaël
szames s de public sénat qui nous
rejoint
bonsoir michaëlle jean michel bonsoir
monsieur dupont-aignan est ce que cette
élection présidentielle pour vous et un
référendum pour ou contre l'union
européenne c'est pas que ça parce que je
voudrais quand même rappeler ce que
c'est qu'une présidentielle
on élit la personnalité qui nous
représente qui incarne la france qui
élève le débat et dans cette campagne
c'est pourquoi j'avais envie de débattre
avec les autres
quel est notre philosophie de l'action
comment veut hisser le pays
comment on veut rassembler les français
je veux dire il faudrait peut-être
prendre un peu de hauteur
alors oui monsieur dupont s'attendait
aussi à l'otan des les pro-européens les
audiences raison je crois que le débat
ne sera moins droite gauche mais il va
être plus est ce que la france est
encore maître de son destin
et est-ce qu'on l'ait de manière
paisible ou plus excessives
je voudrais que la fesci s'est coincé je
n'aurai que la france reprenne son
destin en main je suis patriote
humaniste voilà je suis patriote
humaniste est votre définition du
candidat nicolas dupont aignan griezmann
isba et gaulliste c'est quoi c'est un
patriote qui défend les français et la
france mais qui le fait avec générosité
en rassemblant alors laissez les
élections se passent et je n'ai pas à
révéler candidats entendus mais de
marion maréchal-le pen arrêter de me
parler de x ou y je suis candidat à
l'élection directement mais moi je vous
réponds je m'adresse aux français au
lieu qui va y avoir choisiront le
patriotisme qu'il préfère vous l'esprit
de soumission d'un vieux système pourri
et je pense que le patriotisme humaniste
de bon sens que je propose est meilleur
que celui du front national alors je
serai pas candidat mais vous dites
qu'ils libèrent y avoir des surprises au
cours de cette élection il ya une
inquiétude qui monte à l'étranger
particulièrement sur une possible
victoire de marine le pen au second tour
nicolas dupont aignan est ce que vous
vous avez cette angoisse d'une victoire
de la présidente du front national g
l' angoisse de voir mais la question
c'est s'il est précisé qu'à moi je
réponds ce que je veux encore ava la
question quand même que moi j'ai
l'angoissé de voir une élection
présidentielle manipulé par un système
aux abois qui veut nous rendre
prisonnier d'un choix impossible et je
veux offrir aux français un vrai choix
pour un beau patriotisme républicain et
social avec des solutions sur l'emploi
on en a peu parlé vous m'avez parlé des
autres mais pas de mes propositions sur
l'hôpital public sur la santé des
médecins
les médecins en zone rurale sur le monde
rural on est au salon de l'agriculture
qui entraîne mourir un tiers des
français sont abondamment des pourront
lire votre livre wii pourront lire mais
c'est curieux quand vous invitez les
autres on pose des questions sur le
programme on pose des questions sur les
autres une question qui résume tous les
voiliers à ces messieurs du palio
demande
non attendez j'ai des propositions sur
l'école publique
l'instruction plus qu'un ministère de
l'instruction publique j'ai des
propositions concrètes pour redonner
confiance aux français sur l'écologie
une écologie e durable pas à ces espèces
de 2 comment dire d'originaux qui ont
cassé les verts j'ai des propositions et
j'aimerais que les français regardent
mes solutions et quand ils vont voir la
qualité du projet que je porte et la
qualité des gens qui m'accompagnent
eh bien je pense qu'on peut changer les
choses et je leur fais un appel à eux
ne vous laissez pas intoxiquer vous
réveillez pas le 24 avril en lui disant
ah mince tiens j'aurais dû réfléchir
avant de voter
ça fait 30 ans que vous votez pour les
mêmes il serait temps de changer
monsieur dupont-aignan c'est une
question qu'on pose à tous les candidats
à l'élection présidentielle
si vous n'êtes pas au deuxième tour de
l'élection pression visage pas cette
hypothèse d'accord du deuxième tour
d'élections présidentielles envisager
l'hypothèse emmanuel macron face à marie
lise lâche pas que fin c'est que je vais
vous dire pourquoi je refuse cette
question c'est parce que vous mettez
dans la tête des français qui aurait que
ça comme choix et voulait conditionner
pour qu'ils votent ça au premier tour et
ce faisant vous interdisait aux français
de voter en leur âme et conscience
et bien ce lavage de cerveau gigantesque
lavage de cerveau incroyable sur toutes
les chaînes de télé de radio c'est un
lavage de cerveau et moi je fais appel à
l'intelligence des français à leur bonne
conscience alors lucidité d'un vieux
peuple millénaire qui a envie de vivre
etc a pas envie de partir dans des excès
ou dans la médiocrité qu'on vit depuis
20 ans eh bien je refuse ce
conditionnement mental médiatiques et
politiques du peuple français
bon je le refuse et je suis là justement
pour l'éviter et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'on veut pas m'inviter
parce que ça y est ça gênerait beaucoup
ceux qui sont autour de la table et sera
librement et je faisais la première fin
convention et je le sais la question
vous sera posée le soir du premier tour
d'élection président mais n'ont pas ce
que j'ai réfléchi ministre et monsieur
michael à metz vous devriez poser la
question aux autres qu'est ce que vous
faites si à dupont aignan macron leur
posant est en tout cas je peux vous dire
que si c'est dupont aignan macron il ya
beaucoup plus de chances d'éviter macron
que cissé fillon macron le pen macro
merci nicolas dupont aignan je
représente beaucoup
oui alors mon agenda de présidence
assure l'original le 8 que je raconte ma
présidence oui absolument faire mentir
ces centres terminé davance mêmes et
même vos ministres pressentis merci à
vous pour une prochaine retour en studio
avec césar à faire maintenant l'invité
de l'épreuve de vérité sera jean
christophe cambadélis le premier
secrétaire du ps bonsoir à tous
[Musique]
il